hello everyone and welcome to the game
that brought gookish over 27.50 in the
live standings I'm sure you guys already
uh have heard it it was pretty difficult
getting the game as all of the pigeons
across all of the platforms are broken
uh Sugar Shack from just base India
managed to get the full game I imagine
from Lucas himself so I um uh of course
uh well I'm sure that that the PGN is
correct and uh 2750 is an incredible
rating well well once you reach that
2700 a rating and you go over it you are
considered a super Grand Master okay
maybe now even 2750 can be considered a
super Grand Master because quite a few
people have done it I have no idea how
many people broke 27.50 because in the
live ratings there are uh well sometimes
there there's been between 30 and 50
players are over 2700 and over 27.50 not
a lot of them that's basically you know
you're stepping into the top 10 of the
world and the currently goukash is
number 11 we're going to discuss that
after we check out the game so let's
check it out his opponent is a
clementi's teacher the Russian
Grandmaster and even though there's
quite a bit of a raiding difference
bookish is over 200 rating points higher
rated it's a very very complicated game
and it was not an easy feat uh grabbing
that full point because you know even
when Magnus is playing you know he when
he was um like 20 28 60 28 70. he was
even 28-84 but uh well even when you
face the 20 25 50 Grand Master he can if
he wants to play for a draw you're gonna
have a really hard time actually winning
that game so let's check it out bookish
has the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to F3 he opts for that 80 opening
Knight F6 G3 we have Pawn to D5 and now
Bishop to G2 so the standard King's
Indian attack the Yugoslav variation
Pawn to C5 and here we have castles we
have born to G6 D for now and C captures
on D4 Knight captures Bishop to G7 and
now it's the B3 so it's a not the the
rarest of lines but a fairly rare one
but it has been played by some very
strong players Nakamura played it Anand
played that alireza played it so yeah
he's in known uh territory we have
castles Knight to C3 now putting
pressure on the D5 Pawn so you have to
react to that uh Pawn to E6 and now Pawn
to A4 grabbing more space on the queen
side we have Knight to C6 and now Pawn
to A5 and there is a game where D4 was
played but here we have Rook to E8 by
Clementi and it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game so
Pawn to H3 and now Pawn to H6 both of
them creating some room for the Kings on
H2 and H7 respectively and now Bishop to
E3 this is a beautiful move that really
makes you I appreciate the the strength
of a 2750 Grandmaster uh because okay
you uh you're playing a game you're
developing your pieces okay you've
grabbed some space on the queen side
your Knights are on very nice squares
the bishop is on this beautiful diagonal
you've already castled so you're
probably thinking about how do I play
King H2 how do I play E4 F4 and you know
how do I attack something uh and while
E3 isn't all that spectacular yes you
are preventing D4 in pretty much all the
lines but then you are blocking your own
dark Square Bishop from being developed
and on the other hand uh well E4 might
be a bit too premature we can even show
it like E4 since it's a classical game
E4 what if D4 happens then you kind of
have to play E5 and already you go into
some trades that might not be all that
favorable for you or some real captures
e captures on F6 Bishop captures after B
captures Bishop captures you get this
position where the Rook is attacked and
if let's say Rook E3 version B4 and you
might already be forced into some sort
of a repetition or you know even being
forced to play slightly worse position
if you want to actually continue the
game so after Point H6 Lucas plays this
bishop to E3 move which you'll see is
very very interesting Knight to E5 now
getting the Knight to C4 is the idea
where the Knight will be pressuring the
B2 Pawn so we could Place Queen to C1
now putting pressure on that H not that
weird arrow on that H6 pawn and King to
H7 the King was bound to come to H7 at
some point so this is now basically uh
getting the king to H7 with Tempo Rook
the D1 nicely aligning The Rook with the
black queen and now Knights the C4
attacking the bishop and the B2 Pawn so
of course you didn't put the bishop on
E3 to allow the knights to capture it
bookish plays Bishop to C5 very very
unique moves with the bishop here Bishop
to D7 and now only Now Pawn to E4 and
now you would welcome the opening of the
e-file since the queen is on the same
file as The Rook so Knight captures an
E4 uh probably a safer approach with
something like B6 or just getting the
Queen off of the that a d file but he
goes for Knight captures on e4 Knight
captures an E4 D captures and Bishop
captures on e4 and now look at this he
can capture the pawn on B2 he can even
capture it with the bishop why is
gookish allowing this why is he giving
up the exchange here well he's really
not because if Bishop captures on B2 yes
you are attacking the rook and the queen
but look at this queen F4 and now you
have to worry about the F7 Pawn but it's
not easy to
uh get out of this if if you move the
queen then the bishop on D7 hangs so uh
the the just the idea of this queen
sharing the same file as The Rook is
problematic for you so you're gonna play
King to gate defend the pawn here but
now Bishop captures some B7 and if let's
say Rook to V8 now you're gonna play
Pawn to A6 you don't give up you don't
really um care about the rook and A1 if
if captures then captures you're gonna
capture on A7 uh and you're gonna win
back your exchange eventually but it's
not like you even want to you actually
would appreciate the position even more
if you could uh operate the bishop pair
with the Rook being absolutely useless
on V8 uh so that's kind of the idea so
instead Knight captures on B2 was played
as you've seen Bishop capture some B2 is
too dangerous uh Queen to F for still
putting pressure on F7 and now Pawn to
F5 attacking the bishop and now Bishop
captures some B7 so like I said we're
gonna see something similar only Now The
Rook on D1 is being captured with the
rook and A1 being threatened and now
Rook captures on D1 now the the other
Rook takes over the D file and the queen
is still on d8 and now Pawn to E5 and
this is what I said at the beginning of
the video that the pigeons all over the
world and all the platforms were broken
because all of them said that after E5
uh Clementi resigned the game and he had
some three minutes on the clock had
maybe 20 minutes on the clock so I
actually thought this was correct even
though the position is completely equal
and the engine gives it the 0.00 it's
not that easy to find moves problem is
let's say uh okay let's say you play
something like Queen to F3 it's a it is
a drawn position but you have to find
moves let's say queen F3 Rook to B8 to
attack the bishop now A6 that will
always happen and this is a hypothetical
line and now of course if you capture
that's just bad so let's say queen to C7
and now you will play Bishop to D6
attack the queen here or you don't even
have to you will play Bishop captures on
A7 threaten The Rook here so there are
many options and now if you move the
Rook okay you still have the two Rooks
but they're useless nice the C5 and now
after Bishop to C8 you can do some
trades here let's say Rook captures real
captures and now even Queen to C6 you
you're done material but you force a
queen trade captures captures and now
let's say Bishop f8 goes after the
Knight Bishop to B6 goes after The Rook
but also now your uh A7 and A8 squares
are covered so A7 A8 will win the game
and here black would have to give back
the material Bishop captures and C5
Bishop capture 78 and now Bishop
captures an A6 and okay it's an equal
game equal material both players have
the bishop pair uh you know completely
completely even however uh after Pawn to
E5 Google played Queen to C4 which is a
bit more complicated uh as you'll see a
rook the C8 he wants to give up The Rook
because the bishop is just an absolute
monster so Pawn to A6 guccish nut in a
rush to trade this and queen to C7 uh we
have Queen to B4 just getting the queen
out of the way uh and now Bishop to E6
here uh black still has a very good
chance if black found Pawn to F4 uh
Clementi would have good chances here
for example G for now E4 and what do you
do well okay you could you could capture
back capturing the rook and C8 would be
a bit too dangerous so Bishop captures
an E4 now probably Bishop to C6 you
trade the Bishops and black is very much
back in the game however after Bishop to
E6 and now gookish plays bishop captress
and C8 and you should capture with the
bishop to cover the B7 square but uh
Clementi played a rook captures on C8
and now Queen the B7 offers a queen
trade and of course you cannot trade
this you don't wanna give him the the
pass Pawn on B7 so King to H it was
played and King tachet is a pretty
pretty tough blunder here with F4 you're
you're still in the game point is that
uh
uh now you have to actually defend you
cannot just go upon grabbing because
after Bishop captures 10 A7 now there's
Queen captures on C2 attacking the rook
and if Rook to D2 then you have Queen to
B1 check and if King to G2 then Queen to
E1 and uh your uh very much still in the
game now if let's say Bishop to C5 you
want to start pushing your pawn queen F5
threatens Queen T for check to win the
White Queen and even if you move the
King still Queen a bishop to E4 attacks
the queen and threatens Checkmate it's
game over so uh while F4 is not uh
winning by force for black it is
definitely the best move which prevents
Bishop characters on A7 uh in the game
King the h8 was played and now we have
Bishop captures on A7 uh Queen to C3 now
you can't capture on C2 because then
Rook to C1 is Just Deadly so Knights the
C5 now cuts the Queen's defense of the
Rook here and also the bishop is
attacked here on E6 which uh indirectly
defends The Rook directly but uh you
know metaphorically indirectly me Queen
captures on C2 and now Rook to F1 Google
should go forward with Rook to D6 but he
uh he he had he knows he has a winning
position he doesn't want to risk too
much we have Queen to C for now uh and
Knight captures on E6 Queen captures and
now a beautiful Bishop to B8 cutting off
The Rook from uh defending that A8
Square Ponta F4 now it's uh you know
yeah you have to go all out otherwise
you can just resign Ponte A7 Queen
captures on H3 A8 Queen Lucas now with
two Queens on the board and F captures
and G3 so Lucas with the two queens uh
Clementi threatening mate in one feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the quickest way to win this for gookish
while I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
foreign
who were able to do it congratulations
on always looking for the move that uh
you know is the most fun and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Queen captures and G7 did not play
this Google's played Queen to G2 because
that's just you know it's even more
funny because it just says I have an
extra Queen and you don't so I can play
pretty much any move on the board but if
you wanted to really end the game you
would play Queen captures and G7 but it
requires calculating and there's no
reason to do that when you're completely
winning so which is on the king captures
Bishop captures on E5 with check and now
however you play it you are just gonna
lose if you go up the board then okay
this um uh well well let's say King to
F7 you don't want to allow any
unnecessary weird checks let's say queen
D5 check if King T8 now you can go Queen
to G8 with check and knife 13 to D7
Queen to F7 with check and after King to
C6 now finally Rook to C1 with check you
will pick up the rook and Checkmate the
black king but even when the King was an
F file you could also just capture the
pawn open up a discovery everything is
winning here yeah but in the game
gookers played Queen to G2 even more
funny because it really just says I have
an extra Queen why are we still playing
uh and uh yeah g captures an F2 check
was played Queen captures and F2 and he
was in this position on move 35 that
Clement is each have resigned in the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here uh once once another check is given
you can pretty much bring the other
Queen here attack the black queen here
and again you make the same statement
I'm up a queen I mean let's let's not be
serious about this game anymore so yeah
really nicely done by gookash he becomes
the youngest player ever to uh to bridge
the 25 sorry the 2750 barrier which is
absolutely incredible and he's the third
ever Indian who achieved that first one
of course being vishwanathan second one
being pentala Hari Krishna and of course
being the third and here we have it uh
these are the standings now Magnus still
the only player over 2800 in classic
called Nakamura in strong second with
2787 carvana with 2782 dinglier in 2780
Jani pondichi
277977 anishigiri 2769 dropped a few
points there Wesley so 2769 a
vishwanathan Anand still in top 10 2754.
uh rehab airport 2752 and now yeah also
Lucas jumps up to two spots 27.50 in
number 11 currently so I don't know if
he will be playing any more games until
the end of the month if not he will get
an actual rating of 27.50 but if he does
you know maybe he wins even more so he
will come out with an even higher rating
uh yeah so that's uh the game hope you
guys enjoyed it a bit of a complicated
one and you see how it's really not easy
like I said he's over 200 points higher
rated than Clementi here uh but he still
had to work very very hard for his meal
and you know had Clementi made some
better choices uh it would um uh you
know uh work better for him but it's not
only about the position because the
glucose was also uh always far ahead on
time Clementi was basically in time
travel for for the last 20 moves so also
that's something uh to consider he had
to spend a lot more time in order to you
know play on equal terms with gookish
and then of course uh the the 2750
caliber really started showing uh so
yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank bullet
just thriller.com
Gage windland uh chomuk and Rod Hill for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day